well I grew up here and my father play
in a Piano Trio setting and seeing him
put together Rhythm sections for great
musicians like sunny stit and Clark
Terry whenever they played New Orleans
and
singles this gave me a special love and
feeling for the Rhythm Section piano
bass and
drum I want all of y'all to start
noticing Rhythm sections when you see
them Rhythm sections are
everywhere all over the world
this afternoon in hotel lounges tonight
in clubs fulfilling different functions
for small Gatherings of people paying
scant to no
attention you could be the greatest harm
player in the world but you tried
playing a two-hour gig with no Rhythm
Section they're seated behind you but
they determine the overall environment
of every moment the Rhythm Section
understands better than anyone that jazz
requires servant
leadership throughout the 20th century
Jazz expanded and sent his greatest
soloist around the world with messages
of peace love and like Rob was saying
Universal
humanism during the same time frame our
same world was pockmarked with death
spots murderers and strong men who would
be king for some reason when given the
choice between participating in our own
Affairs or abdicating
responsibility to ass solve every
problem through persecuting someone else
King a population just loves to choose
that strong
man it's actually very Primal and
simple that King is going to punish
other
persons he's doing it for us
because the best way to ameliorate our
anxiety to ameliorate our anxiety is to
find some designated unfortunates to
sacrifice for a just cause of
course this is an age old and very sad
script these other persons need to be
chastised for being
themselves the anointed strongman
oppresses and eliminates other person
but eventually he starts attacking and
liquidating a random selection of his
own people for conspiring against him I
mean the
state and because he has a lifetime
appointment the king administers Swift
Justice to a broad swath of the very
people that initially supported his
kingship as his supporters perish they
patriotically Shout long live the
king a king in jazz does the complete
opposite Jazz comes from the
experience of other
persons therefore our royalty elevates
the supposed enemy instead of
subjugating them the music has clear
practices designed to constrain the
Dominion of the powerful for example a
soloist can stand up and and play as
long as they want but if you get too
carried away and the Rhythm Section does
a thing called breathing when you
playing too
long they rededicate that means please
stop playing if you walk through two of
those breaths guess what they're going
to
do you don't want to play with us you
got
this one
horn that's a pretty sad sound after a
while they let you have it and they just
look at
you and when you finish they look at you
like
okay